Keith only uses lambskin condoms because
after sex he enjoys a snack Anna's just
jealous because my body is shaped like
the eggs she can no longer produce keep
juicing some bold cuz I'm for years past
his life expectancy
look I don't want to say Anna's
desperate for love but I did see her
standing in front of a Home Depot
wearing a wedding dress he told me he
has a really big dick which makes sense
the average blue whale penis is eight to
ten feet Anna has a long face buck teeth
and she once a married man what
I'm saying is she's a horse that caused
divorce with no remorse of course of
course he's a fat bisexual so you could
his neck his back his and his
crap that's absolutely true like I go
both ways just like Anna's shitty tits
no honestly I think Anna's just jealous
because my parents get to watch the
battle on TV and hers have to watch from
wherever Mexicans go instead of heaven
oh my god
delay it looks in shock that's really
tough I mean those were both great no
cookies definitely the weirdest show on
television got a vote
who you like world peace I think when he
said boos went different directions I
think that was false she has great boobs
[Applause]
security we have a horny NBA player in
the belly room
it was a tie and this that you had a
false statement I gave it to end I'm
gonna give it to you because you're just
nothing fazed you you just rolled with
everything there was not at no twitchy
face you just erects you're like twitch
because I keep looking you in my
eyeballs try to kill themselves all
right can we wrap this up so she can get
back to looking for the six-fingered man
who killed her father
[Applause]
I enjoyed both of you I think you guys
are fantastic I'm just gonna give it to
Anna because she for me after her jokes
would I like she did she did this little
watching you it's 2-1 Keith Jeff I don't
think there's any doubt that lambskin
condoms joke wanted for me and uh Keith
you're a true competitor you've been
doing you've done what 19 battles yeah
it's amazing how you're a killer but I
gotta say I really think this was Anna's
night so congratulations darling you got
it aside from the part that I didn't win
it went exactly how I wanted it to go
she came hard nothing fazed her it was
perfect I love you and I'm gonna be
fertile for the next 20 years it
shouldn't
[Applause]